tell me about the uh
tell me the story about the girl you met
who was a scientologist okay now that
was
the bet one of the best dates i've that
was the out of the two or three days the
three there was three days out of that
three dates
that chick amazing really was she the
hottest
yeah but i don't think that had anything
to do with it really yeah so she was hot
i mean like extremely like usually you
get there and you're like oh
man you gave me glamour shot pictures
you really picked the best pictures of
you
this chick walked in and walked up and
over to me and i was just like
oh my god run the numbers run the
numbers for me
run the numbers what was her what was
her cup size what was her height not
doing that she was an attractive woman
what am i 12. does she have a fat ass
fat i'm not gonna say this paint us a
picture
who says what are you doing you're a
white guy you can't get a picture yeah i
like a fat ass oh my god
you you're this is horrible you're a
horrible individual
matt this is what this is what what we
do this is what we like
listen she was extremely attractive
she i don't know what's happening here
put your phone down put your phone down
oh it's my cutscene that's great put
your phone down
the doctor threw a hundred dollars the
doctor yeah but not to me he threw it to
danny
shout out to the doctor unbelievable the
doctor
benjamin that guy so um so paint a
picture for us what shoot
yeah blondes yeah she had brown hair
brown
brownish blonde five foot four maybe
five no
maybe five three actually how much think
she weighs
oh 100 510 110 pounds
okay maybe max 115. how the
what are the breasts double d big big
she had plenty she was very attractive
she was
what does that mean plenty of plenty she
was average
average okay i'm good with average i
don't know i don't want to date a freak
show
okay not giant melons triple d's big old
ass
i'm with you on that a big fan not
interested i like little i like little
tiny natural
right that's all i need i'm good yeah i
i need some
something ridiculous so okay so yeah so
how old was she i want to say she's in
her
oh she i think she was like 41 42 years
old actually i think she was so
let's say 40. okay um she had her [ __ ]
together
scientologists they have their yeah
she's definitely she was sharp as attack
and we sat down we started talking and
this is what was so funny was i had
mentioned
during our conver our texts she had said
you seemed great you seen this i said
yeah well it's not all it cuts
it sounds i said trust me there's
there's an issue and she's like well
what's the issue i said i'll i'll
mention it to you
when we meet in person so we talked for
about two hours like we had
dinner and about an hour and a half into
it let's say hour and a half into it
maybe two hours
she says you seem so funny and great
like we were having a great time
and she goes she said what's the issue
and i went what's the catch here cox i
said all right here's
here's here's the catch and i explain
like you know
here's what's going on boom boom boom i
go through the whole on the run
in cars i knocked it i didn't in 30
minutes i got maybe the 30 minute
version because the
two-hour version will freak you out i
said i'm gonna go with 30 minutes here
and she's okay
she goes she's i'm ready i said okay so
i tell her the 30 minute version boom
give her the 30 minute version and
um and at the end of it she goes look
i'm not gonna lie she said that
that that gives me pause she said but
you know i
i mentioned to you that i'm a science
scientologist you know so and people
some people have issues with that
she said so she said i told you that up
front
you know because i wanted you to know
that um she said so but this is this is
that's a big one
i said it is a big one and she goes let
me think about it let me think about it
she's about to
i think i'm going to be okay with the
shoes but let me think about it she's i
have to kind of
have to kind of pass it by she had to
consult with she had basically had to
talk to you know she didn't say in my
opinion
she made it sound like she had to pass
it by someone
right yeah should i talk to zenu the
galactic overlord i don't know who that
is
so el ron hubbard i understand i
understand the mocking
um but the point is is that
she we talked listen 30 we talked for we
talked for actually for another two
hours and change
so about 30 minutes later we're talking
and i remember at one point she stopped
and she just leaned in and she goes
do you feel the chemistry between us and
i went
i go yeah it's like that's nuts right
and she goes
it is it's crazy she's like i never feel
this way she said i feel this
this is this is great chemistry and i go
right
so then this goes on we end up going
into the bar we sit in the bar we talk
for another hour in the bar
we're leaning in and talking and and
finally she says listen she's i i have
to go
sh are you guys drinking at the bar matt
doesn't drink
i know you don't drink but did she drink
i think she had like a why because she
found me interesting
right because she's a scientologist i'm
interested to see if scientologists
drink i don't know she drank or not she
might have had a glass of wine i don't
recall her drinking
to be honest but whatever i'm into the
details matt's okay okay so well we went
to the bar we sat down we i had a diet
coke i don't know what she had
um so we were talking but i mean
literally like another hour or so into
that conversation
she ends up saying she goes look she's
it's late i'm gonna have to go she is
and honestly she said the chemistry
between us is so overwhelming she's i
feel like
like we're gonna she goes i'm gonna kiss
you here she's if i don't leave soon
and i was just like i was like well what
you have to understand too
where we've got the mask she goes to the
church
she can't go to the church if she's
had like contact with me right so they
have all these rules
about that they're trying to keep from
getting
like nobody in that in the church has
gotten coveted okay because they're
extremely stringent on the rules and so
she so anyway
i said okay i said yeah okay that's cool
um and we leave
and she gets in her car and she leaves
and she says look she's i'm gonna call
you tomorrow she said when
you know like i go when you want to see
each other again she said like probably
this weekend i mean
she said i gotta ask some people at the
church
how like about talking was it you know
i'm saying like talking
like like how like actually being with
you like
connecting with you like i need to find
out exactly what the rules are like how
closely i can get how close i can get to
you the whole thing
she said i need to find out exactly what
those rules are
she said but yeah probably like like
this weekend she was i definitely want
to see you again i said okay cool
so that's it the next day
she sends me a text she says i had an
amazing time
you're an amazing guy the chemistry was
overwhelming
she said i find you extremely attractive
interesting she's you're just an amazing
individual all the way around she said i
know that this isn't going to make sense
at all she's but i'm afraid we're going
to have to keep this in the friend zone
she said it i know it doesn't i can't
explain why
i it's i just have to it just can't go
any further than where it is right now
and i'm so sorry
and she's i understand if you'd be upset
about that but i would really like to
keep you as a friend
and i went slow game
so i said i said let me let me explain
something my
my personal um
you know philosophy on having hot female
friends
is that there's just nothing more
useless in the world
than having a hot chick as a friend
because while they think you're building
a friendship
you're i'm thinking how am i gonna [ __ ]
this chick
so i said it's absolutely useless for
you to be a friend i said but
if you're serious about it i'll make an
attempt to be friends
however if it's the kind of friend that
sends me
three texts a week to say hey what's up
and i say oh everything's good
and that's it i said i got enough of
those useless friends already
i said now if you want to actually be a
friend yeah of course why
why do i care this chick's done so
i said you know if you want to be if you
want to meet have dinner if you want to
bounce business ideas because she had
some great business ideas like she like
when i talked to her about my art was
she rich i mean i didn't get into it
what kind of car did you drive
the [ __ ] is going on bro do you are you
really sit there at the first date and
say so what's your financial stuff how
much do you have in the bank
what's in your 401k i don't i don't ask
anything yeah that's how it works now
matt
no well scientologists aren't rich yeah
they are bro are you kidding me
the higher-ups bro a lot of
scientologists are rich as [ __ ]
not the ones that walk up and down the
street in the [ __ ] in the white
clothes no not those those are just the
slaves
there's literally slaves in scientology
tell her you'll take
the brain zap and test and [ __ ] if
that's what they want yeah get audited
listen did she want they don't want me
as a member did she say
i wouldn't be a member of any church
that would have me as a member did she
say that she's ever seen any of your
videos online
uh no i'm no she hadn't seen anything
she didn't know anything about me
remember she only knew my name was matt
that's all she knew until that night so
scientologists aren't allowed to use the
internet from what i hear that's not
true bro that's not true i talk to this
chick all the time like i
i texted her does she have youtube yeah
she's got you she's watched my stuff
now oh she's watched my stuff she's
listen she's got like a real corporate
job she doesn't work for scientology she
has a corporation
corporate job i mean she it must have
been a while ago but i interviewed
multiple people on here uh one of the
guys ron miscavige i
interviewed he's the dad of david
miscavige who is the
[ __ ] overlord of scientology right
you're probably the reason she won't
[ __ ] see me they probably found out
i'm connected to you and probably
they're like oh no he's connected to for
sure
to danny jones we're matchmaking over
here not masterpiece you destroyed my
[ __ ] match
i've interviewed that i've interviewed
it up you know we laid it up to you
anyways all these guys people tell me
that the scientologists that
maybe it's just the ones who live at the
like the actual church the people who
live there like the residents
they're not allowed to use the internet
like they have internet but it's very
limited like they can't use youtube or
anything like that and their search
options are limited
all right so scientology is no more
ridiculous than christianity
it is a little bit different i didn't
say different i didn't say it wasn't
different ridiculous i said it's no
more ridiculous